America I think we might have just found
the epicenter of lawlessness stupid
liberal policies and incompetent leaders
welcome to San Francisco shocking video
shows a mob of teenagers at the mall
going wild viciously attacking and
stopping each other for the third time
this month
to CNN correspondence covering rampant
Street crime got a taste of some San
Francisco Hospitality after their rental
car was broken into even though they had
security watching it but hey it's no big
deal if your stuff gets stolen this
ex-san Francisco police Commissioners
calling car robbery a basic City life
experience
and while the city drowns in crime
officials biggest Focus right now is
reparations
a plan that a former BLM leader thinks
is offensive and is predicted to cost
600 billion all right judge
that's the next Police Commissioner
that's basically confessing that this
it's just something that happens here
this is what I love he says car
robberies are basic City life experience
or if you're so weak that the robbery
will break you maybe you shouldn't live
in the city oh god really okay but
here's the best part of it in 2020 mayor
London breed reduced the funding for the
police something like 120 million
dollars so there we are with or here we
are with the mo with these teens roaming
around assaulting each other going into
malls assaulting bystanders the other
teams are are videotaping it not getting
involved and why don't you get involved
they say because we don't want to be a
victim okay but the best part of it is
they had to hire cops that are not at
the level that that is standard some of
them don't have proof of citizenship for
one thing 50 of them I think that was a
number that didn't pass a psychological
profiles one cop shot a husband and a
wife oh boy that one of these uh uh
picks when they lowered the standards so
they asked for it they got this guy uh
in office but actually the new D.A is
someone who's very I think is going to
be very good but this is what you get
when you defund the police KR a chaos
and Anarchy and no one wants to live
there and the values of homes go down
businesses leave schools become a mess
and and the quality of life for everyone
is reduced so yeah we like the suburbs
how do you handle teens throwing down in
a mall like that I I don't know we
didn't I grew up in New York City and we
only had one mall and I didn't go in it
I actually only went to a big mall for
the first time when I went to college it
was really this is Jessica okay
no but I went to a Cheesecake Factory
for the first time anyway
um this is terrible uh I grew up in a
city I did grow up in a nicer
neighborhood but it's not been a fact of
life for anyone that I know I know very
few people who have had their car
windows smashed in or any of this but
you know Coming of Age story you get cat
called right that's what should be
happening if you're growing up in a city
not something like this
um the new D.A I'm glad the judge says
that it seems like is that something I
think
um but the recall election for the DEA
was the Asian Community First of all
speaking out the most on this but people
of San Francisco the from the rich to
the poor are fed up you can see op-ed's
everywhere about this so they're saying
you're destroying one of the Great
American cities which it definitely is
and when you look at all the layoffs
that are happening now in the tech
sector where people are not going to be
able to afford to stay there anyway and
then you compound it with this they're
going to be looking at huge amounts of
flight out of these cities and people
are hanging on basically as long as they
can because they love it because they
truly love it how I feel about New York
City but you wouldn't you're not going
to push a stroller up one of those Hills
and know that something like this could
be coming down on you and now CNN's
become part of the story covering the
crime wave well finally right and I
think that the Democrats who lost in
2022 when they were about because of
crime like Lori Lightfoot has really
opened the eyes that's even when you had
President Biden saying something not
much to add I mean everything I I agree
with I think the vicious cycle of a
dwindling tax base is going to continue
so that even if you want to put more
money into preventing homelessness you
won't have that kind of tax base it's
not just that won't just happen in San
Francisco but it will happen everywhere
especially as technology continues to
improve and people either lose their
jobs or get the freedom to make a choice
to leave the city have you been to San
Francisco recently it's a beautiful city
no I haven't
I haven't but it is a gorgeous City
maybe it was I don't know I mean it grew
up around there what upsets me is how
lopsided all of this is you know where
the crazy right-wing towns have you ever
thought of that do you know MSNBC and
CNN by the way CNN they only cover the
crime wave because they were part of it
I mean they were victims that's what it
took but I mean like you don't see the
others like where is the where are the
places run by the Aryan Nations plagued
by white supremacists you know where
where Asians are beaten by white
skinheads where is that City you know
it's all these attacks on Asians
all the blacks being murdered right you
know all the carjackings and all the
thefts they're in Crazy left-wing towns
it's not fair to the crazy right-wing
towns where is their Town how is that
possible could that happen as for this
guy who said that you know uh uh theft
and car robbery is part of city life so
it was rape so I mean that's really not
a good ex it's not really a good
explanation to a victim to television
you know what ma'am you got raped part
of the big city huh what are you gonna
do you know it's sad that criminals
Target hard-working women and Asians and
elderly and not him because after all he
doesn't seem to mind it right maybe go
after him instead of the women right all
right I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now